let's talk about what would happen if
you had poor sleep for 14 days i'm
talking about
like less than six hours and you had
crappy sleep now i do want to say some
people can get away with less sleep but
the majority of us need at least seven
to eight hours
so what actually happens over time if
you're sleep deprived well i think this
might shock you because what you have to
realize every single cell in your body
is connected to this internal clock that
controls your circadian rhythms so let's
go through this first of all you're
going to be tired right you're going to
have chronic fatigue you're not going to
have the energy then your cognitive
function will definitely suffer
your memory is not going to be that
great you're going to lose creativity
imagination
coming up with good ideas
i know with myself i need a really good
night's sleep to constantly come up with
these wonderful videos that i'm doing
for you and then you have focus and
concentration are going to be off so
you'll have brain fog
your mood will suffer okay you're going
to have more anxiety more depression
more irritability
you're going to have more overall stress
in other words you're not going to be a
happy camper all right your heart is
greatly influenced by your sleep
the risk for getting a heart attack goes
up the risk of getting a stroke goes up
people tend to have more high blood
pressure when they're not sleeping so if
you think about it the heart has to
constantly pump 24 7. it doesn't have a
chance of sleep unless when you're
sleeping it can rest a little bit but
when you're going through the day and
you're exercising or going through
stress that is more strain in the heart
so at the very least it needs a good
night rest to recoup and recover
your hormones the endocrine system is
greatly influenced by your sleep cycles
testosterone libido is negatively
affected by poor sleep infertility is
another issue if you have poor sleep if
you don't sleep that well your
inflammation goes up you might have more
pain you get worsened blood sugars okay
because the cortisol that increases when
you're not sleeping the stress hormone
is a glucocorticoid so your body starts
making more sugar even when you're not
eating it so you start to have worsen
blood sugars
that's going to lead to more weight gain
people don't realize that the majority
of fat that you they burn is at night
when they're sleeping okay if you're not
sleeping guess what you're not going to
lose weight and you could potentially
gain weight your immune system is highly
influenced by the quality of sleep
people that don't sleep are more
susceptible to getting infections
because they have a weakened immune
system but other than these minor
complications
it probably is not going to affect you
that bad now let's talk about what can
you do if you have poor sleep well
there's a lot of different factors i'm
going to cover
all of them in this video
you do need this thing called oxygen
when you sleep okay now if you have
sleep apnea that is a problem with
insulin resistance and if you don't know
what i'm talking about i'm going to put
a link down below
of how to fix insulin resistance there
are several plants that produce a lot of
oxygen that can help you sleep and give
you more oxygen one is pothos which i
think is called devil's ivy and the
other is peace lily you can keep these
in your room and they'll produce more
oxygen for you so you can sleep better
this is one reason why people tend to
sleep better with the window open
but
oxygen is very important especially when
you're sleeping
now is light important when you're
sleeping well you want no lights when
you're sleeping and unfortunately
we have lights 24 7. and if you live in
the city you have more lights and people
don't go to bed when it gets dark out at
night in fact a lot of times they'll go
to bed at midnight if you think about
what is midnight it's the middle of the
night
it's not the beginning of the night it's
the middle of the night so it's very
important not to wait till midnight i
know with myself if i go past midnight
then i have to literally wait like 90
minutes before i can get get into a deep
sleep because of the circadian waves i
go to bed between 9 30 and sometimes 10
30 at the very latest but light is a
very huge factor okay
especially blue light now a lot of the
lights in your house have blue light in
them as well as your computer screens
your cell phone
and that blue light inhibits melatonin
now red light or infrared light
increases melatonin so if you are using
incandescent lights in your house that's
a very very good thing because that will
give off a lot of infrared or your
fireplace will give up infrared
candles are infrared a fire and a
campfire will give off infrared which is
all really good to build up melatonin
which can then help you sleep at night
what's interesting about melatonin is
that it doesn't necessarily cause
sleepiness but it is involved in the
circadian rhythms and you need enough of
it to be able to get into this this
sleep cycle but apparently when people
take it during the day they
usually don't get tired
however there are exceptions including
myself if i took melatonin i would
probably want to take a nap so
blue light inhibits melatonin and messes
up your sleep and red light or infrared
enhances your sleep because it increases
melatonin i personally wear a little
mask when i go to bed because i don't
want to have any light and i really make
sure that my room is dark right before
bed
because the less that you're going to be
tired and be able to drift off into that
wonderful sleep that you need now what
about temperature that's very important
as well you want your room to be on the
cooler side between 64 and 68 degrees
fahrenheit okay
you can do the conversions for celsius
but the point is that your body tends to
sleep better when it's cooler versus
when the room is hot i remember in
college
my air conditioner broke down and it was
in the middle of
summer
and i did not sleep one minute it was
literally torture because it was so hot
outside
and in my little tiny apartment which
was an attic by the way
all right what about liquids should you
drink right before bed well not if you
have a problem urinating okay through
the night i recommend try to get most of
your water um right around dinner time
and not pass that and that way you can
avoid getting up to the night if you
have a problem getting up to the night
like some people do
there's a great solution for that it's
fixing your insulin resistance i will
put that link down below but if you're
getting up 10 times a night
that's going to mess up your sleep
all right what about if you have pain
or inflammation like in your back and
you're trying to sleep
well the solution for that is usually
vitamin d3 and you want to take about 10
000 international units
before bed and that should usually
handle any type of lower back pain
that's occurring
and vitamin d in general for most people
before bed will help them sleep now i
will say there are certain people that
it doesn't work on so you might want to
test it out now what about noise well
i wear earplugs okay because i am a
light sleeper
probably
this stemmed from being in basic
training and being rudely awakened at
four o'clock in the morning for
three months but noise is a big factor
some people can't wear earplugs
i can and it seems to work
what about
thinking and solving problems what do
you do about that well
a really good solution would be to take
vitamin b1
that helps to turn that off and that can
help you drift off into a better sleep
now one thing that i do which actually
helps me too is um i'm constantly
involved with many different projects
and i have to do lists and i found it's
very very important especially before
bed to write all these things down on a
piece of paper that i have to do the
next day but i kind of work it like this
i don't have this massive list that i
have to get done every single day i will
put maybe i don't know three or four or
five important things
on that to-do list that i must do and
i'll have a lot of other things that if
i have time i will get to but that way i
take a win i actually get things done
and i'm not constantly
feeling like i'm always behind or having
all these
unfinished projects to do what about
cramps in your feet okay that's usually
a magnesium deficiency it could also be
a potassium deficiency and if you get
cramps chances are you need to look at
your eating and finding out what you're
not eating that you should be eating all
right heart rate okay if you have a
higher pulse rate
that is going to affect your sleep
greatly okay that usually is a potassium
deficiency so you need to consume foods
high in potassium which are usually
vegetables in larger quantities i have a
very big salad every single day and it's
between seven to ten cups that usually
will handle your potassium deficiency
you could also do a potassium supplement
i'll put a link down below if you want
more information on that there is
another cause of high pulse rate and
that is your ph is to acid i'll give you
an example let's say in the evening
you drink kombucha tea which is very
very acidic okay and you drink the whole
bottle you may find that your pulse rate
starts going higher okay that happened
with me so
just drink less okay
so what about stress can that
potentially affect your sleep uh yeah i
think so so there's many things you can
do for stress and of course exercise is
at the top of the list but i also want
to mention
that physical work okay
that is
getting something done
is
a little bit better than exercise
because it doesn't give you a chance to
focus in on these problems that are in
your mind you kind of you're working on
something outside your mind and with
exercise it's more planned and you have
more of a chance to think about your
problems but there are many things to
reduce stress ashwagandha is a good
supplement lemon balm tea and vitamin b1
you can get that in the form of
nutritional yeast all right what about
digestion is that important
yeah i recently did a video on
drinking some kefir
before bed
now if you're on the ketogenic plan
maybe you have that right after dinner
kefir has a combination of not just
bacteria but yeast friendly yeast as
well and so when you take that it's
going to help your gut
and you're going to make more
neurotransmitters l-tryptophan serotonin
which turns into melatonin so kefir is a
very good thing to take in the evening
to help your digestive system but if
your digestion is off man that can
really affect your sleep big time
especially if you let's say you ate too
late and you ate way too much
good luck with sleeping all right i
already talked a little bit about
melatonin there's a lot more to talk
about that but one good way to get
melatonin naturally is to be out in the
sun the sun rays
gives out various wavelengths okay and
infrared is one of them and that
increases
melatonin
so if you're out in the sun and i'm not
talking about
being burnt in the sun i'm talking about
before you get burnt okay just getting
sun exposure but even if you actually
wear a hat
and
sunglasses and your clothes
you're still getting infrared it can
penetrate the skin it's fascinating and
you will sleep better if you have this
reserve of melatonin
stimulants like caffeine right if you
drink too much coffee or you're
consuming too much tea or even chocolate
all have stimulants and this is why i
only have like one small cup of coffee
per day because if i have more i find my
sleep is not that great because of my
liver my i've done a lot of damage to my
liver over the years and it's it's not a
hundred percent and so
if i have too much coffee the my liver
cannot detoxify it as much and that also
goes with alcohol it might seem like it
can help you sleep but it actually does
not help you get a rejuvenating sleep
all right and then what about blood
sugars well if your blood sugars are too
high
or too low
that can affect your sleep i want to
mention if you're on the ketogenic plan
your blood sugars will start going lower
and lower and lower it's not a problem
that you're going to have symptoms so
i'm talking about a person has low blood
sugars and they have various symptoms
negative symptoms okay that can affect
their sleep cycle now if you have not
seen my video on melatonin that would be
a really good video for you to watch
next check it out